Tom briefly off-camera you were just
telling us a slogan about NASA and I
thought it relates to something that was
interesting in the beginning of a space
program about how you don't just do
things well it seems like you're a
perfectionist and you you insist on
making sure that it's perfect
well when we say perfectionism it's
often described as an illness and that
might be true but what we say in the
studio is it won't fail because of me it
won't fail because of my part this there
that's that's a great slogan for
collective work and when we put a man on
the moon it was 35,000 people working on
it and each one of them said my small we
might we'll get there if we don't get
there it's not because of something I
didn't do and if everyone really agrees
and believes in that then we can achieve
these incredible things you've said
before you don't take vacations you
don't believe in them therefore do you
ever feel work feels stale because if
you're totally nose to the grindstone
and you believe in making sure that
every part is every I is dotted T
crossed how do you recharge well that's
a great question stanley kubrick never
took vacations and little is known about
how he [ __ ] off but I had to we all
have to do things to regenerate
ourselves I um into really normal stuff
like eating going to the bathroom good
sexual intercourse
sometimes I like to go surfing
weightlifting and skateboarding but
ultimately the the thing when I say
don't take vacations is because I'm
really fulfilled by my work and I'm very
lucky that the thing that I that I get
that I or should say I'm extremely
privileged to be able to work for
passion and do the things that are
important to me which means that there's
a disconnect between things that are
done for money to me the biggest curse
would be to be really well paid to do
something that you didn't love to do
because then you'd be trapped by the
abstract well whereas doing things for
for love or for passion means it doesn't
matter if you're getting paid or not
that's it's a
very very important detail but it's it
means that you can just do what you
believe in and it's important to always
organize life towards that the shaker
has had this expression do the job as if
you had a thousand years to live yet to
die tomorrow well I know people always
say like don't turn your hobby into a
job
find the second thing that you love to
do because once it becomes a job then
its laborious and then you feel somehow
hindered by it yeah I disagree
completely a Dean cammon in slingshot
which is a great documentary about a
Dean cam and the inventor of the Segway
but also the computerized insulin pump
and a lot of amazing biotech stuff said
the key to success is do what you love
and get so good at it that you can make
a living doing it now of course half the
job is doing your job what you love and
the other half is bringing it to the
world which is communications paying
your taxes it's doing interviews writing
and talking about it helping up educate
and teach and share it's important too
it's not just working by yourself in a
garret it's communicating and the movies
that we make van and I are van nice tat
and I are in a way communication aspects
of the sculpture they're like they're
built like the movies that we think are
built just like sculptures but they are
their films so there they have they show
the flaws they're shot with a Canon t2i
with a missing with a missing pixel in
the middle about two-thirds of the way
down from the top of the screen you'll
see one red dot it's almost always there
and I think we're about to get a new
version like the t8i or something I'm
not sure but it's the idea that it's we
we started making movies when iMovie
came out because and then when iMovie
started to become so difficult and not
functional that's when we stopped for
about three years and now we're using
Final Cut
because it's easy again what lenses did
you use because you had such great
intricate close-ups of drills and things
like that which that's the off-the-shelf
Canon zoom lens I don't even remember
the number of it but it's probably
something like a 20 or 30 millimeter to
zoom out to be somewhere between 80 and
120 v it's like a basic off-the-shelf
one it's not even the one with a red
ring on it it's not the good one I think
we bought one of those later when we had
to get another t2i to take a picture of
our t2i for the credit sequence in the
space program we needed we needed a
photo of the cameras we had to buy a
second one just to take a 1 photo of the
first one so these we then returned oh
you did ok so the entire film is shot on
a Canon t2i
its name is baby Jesus and in this
credit sequence you'll see that credit
sequence is shot you'll see the camera
is in it so there is some iPhone footage
also but nothing there's nothing exotic
when we shoot still photos of the
sculptor's those are all shot with like
a 40 ninja pixel Hasselblad digital back
by those are always shocked by Genevieve
Hansen or Joshua white those are stills
and those are for the images that you'll
see in books and on the websites what
was the decision to use a t2 I I mean I
was thinking you use maybe a red or
something it's beautiful but it really
was what van had that's vans camera and
what's important about the t2 I to our
team is that van knows what all the
buttons do and a red has it's a probably
a superior camera in nearly every way
except the you have a huge liability
because it's so expensive the virtue of
a cheap camera is that it's six it's a
it's not an heirloom product it's it's a
consumable even though cameras typically
are understood as consumables the films
the data cards are considered
consumables but when something is that
cheap you can take risks you can
you don't have to take you don't have to
obsess about it and I think a lot of
filmmakers and camera aficionados are
more obsessed with the hardware than
what it's capturing and if something's
only five hundred dollars and you've got
a huge production ahead of you it's
really a relatively small part and that
reversal of economics and power is what
gives us the freedom to make a movie
like we did it's a bar lowering effect
and and also I can't underscore this
enough the knowing how to use the tool
is the most important thing not what the
tool can do as a sculptor I've made much
better work with lower quality tools
that were in my hands that I know that I
have a muscle memory with and a more
precise better tool just because it's
part of my body I'm not thinking so when
Vans getting these shots he doesn't have
to worry about learning about some great
new feature he just goes and speed is
one of the the cornerstones of we have
sort of ten rules of filmmaking please
and rule number one is finish the movie
that's a good rule and most movie makers
don't follow rule number one in most
movies don't get finished and so if you
finish if you if you follow rule number
one that's so much more important than
rules number nine through through
through ten that and we don't always
follow the other rules but we always
follow rule number one what do you think
it's rule number one is not always
what's the reason for that let me start
over again because is it boredom is it I
don't think it's anything to do with
filmmaking I think it's just a question
of character and will and doing what it
takes to get the job done I think it's
bringing the ball to the net metaphor
sports metaphor and doing what it takes
to to get it in the hole like whatever
it takes
it almost and I think we before you ask
me about perfectionism I perfection the
perfect is the enemy of the good or
something like that you know it's this
is not a perfectionist speaking saying
get the movie done because the movie is
flawed and I think if you look at a
space program you'll see tons of flaws
there all these things that are that
aren't perfect about it they're all the
individual sequences are perfect but
it's it's it's flawed it's like it's got
some character flaws and that it's maybe
trying to do too many things or maybe
it's not maybe it's not long enough it
should it would have been a perfect
movie if it had been about three hours
long and we'd shown every little
sequence in order made industrial films
like we originally wanted to do but I
didn't feel that was watchable and that
would be too alienating to the audience
and there's some great filmmakers who
were perfectionist who make more perfect
movies but it was important to us to
make something that people could see I
loved the films of avant-garde sculptors
who make these epic movies but they're
they're really disrespectful to the
viewer and that they don't make it
reasonable to finish the movie and I
think we're living in a time where you
have to make a choice with what your
expectation is of the view are you
trying to and subject them to something
or you're trying to teach them something
or you're trying to share or you're
trying to help them to understand
without thinking I don't I think there
are different kinds of movies for
different kinds of roles we are really
interested in making movies that
illustrate the aspects of the sculptures
that exist in time in other words this
sculpture you know it which is maybe in
a museum at one time was that maybe I
didn't make it let's just say it was a
African mask it was used in a ritual or
this you know this sword was used by a
famous samurai or this sarcophagus was
something that someone was buried in
then and all these the math the sword
the sarcophagus
all had stories and events and things
that occur to them wonder twas four for
a ritual one was for a fight one was
took how's a dead body all those things
are things that existed in time in
action so a lot of the things the
sculptures or the movies about the
sculpture to show how these sculptures
had a history and part of a ritual
activity that was done in the studio we
go to other planets we explore them in
our live demonstrations and these movies
show how we did that of those remaining
nine rules which is the second most
important besides number one do you
think well they're all really mundane
things but they're important and I'm not
going to get them all and I'm not going
to get them right in order but there are
things like right the end of the movie
before you start shooting
don't try and start shooting without
having the end of the story figured out
because the third acts the hard one you
have to understand that before you even
start because if you don't you'll wind
up like that amazing guy a Coppola in
parts of darkness exactly where he's
sitting in the Philippines in a trailer
in the middle of the night typing all
night and shooting all the next day and
not sleeping and that's everything falls
apart I think he got lucky that he got
to finish that movie and it was a
although arguably his greatest film of
one of them the world's greatest film
directors I think it's lucky that it was
a great film and I don't see all those
late nights being the answer I think a
lot of things came together in a kind of
miraculous way that's in it and that's
an anomaly so that's the situation you
want to avoid and I think that if you
look at the history of his life that was
not maybe necessarily a successful
feeling time it was years later that it
became I think it was viewed potentially
as as a failure and it's time and then
only after time became one of the greats
anyway certainly an unhappy thing and
that's that some that we're not looking
to repeat
avoid camera movement hmm especially
with the DSLR like a t2i any camera it's
it's it's it's whether it's a wanted on
a DSLR or red or any camera it's camera
movements of privilege it's not a right
it's an indulgence there's what you
shouldn't you should do it always as
little work as you can an idea shouldn't
be anymore
we had Einstein's said this I'm going to
screw this up everything should be as
simple as possible but no more so in
other words use a tracking shot zoom in
but only to an effect or a better
example maybe is omit unnecessary words
Strunk and white a sculpture should be
as small as it can be to communicate the
idea that might mean it needs to be the
size of a building in some cases but
could also fit in the palm of your hand
everything else is just hubris and ego
2016 filled with franchises and sequels
why should people care about a space
program a we Edward a and homemade and
you the individual we were here in other
words I always wanted my sculptures to
be perfect like an iPhone and I tried
and once I even made a giant sculpture
that was nearly perfect and but there's
some flaws and those flaws really drove
me crazy and and once I kind of started
to embrace those flaws I began to
understand that I could never make
something as flawed as perfect as an
iPhone but Apple can never make anything
as shitty is one of my sculptures and
when I say shitty I really mean showing
evidence of human being was there we're
at a time now where you can have
anything you want made perfectly by
robots we're getting there you can start
to feel it and the virtue of the hand
made the fingerprint is is being
eliminated I think that's also why you
see artisanal movements
see rise in ceramics back my ceramic
bowls when I push my finger into the
clay there's a fingerprint that will be
there for 20,000 years after this whole
building is turned to rubble in all of
our computers have returned to their
inert elements we're going to have a
fingerprint still there in ceramic
underneath all the rubble and shards so
there is I I think with this rise of
robot made stuff you're seeing a rise of
artisanal made things slow food homemade
bicycles knives clothes you're even
seeing people making their own cars from
scratch it's in a way a reaction against
it zine culture is back as a reaction
against websites which and a website
works better than a zine anytime but you
don't get to hand it to someone there's
some there's some sensuality to the
paper that you get to touch it you get
to burn it wipe your ass with it you
know write a love letter on the back of
it it's real